if you're an Olympic athlete or
something like you get to the high you
also have to peek at the time it's an
Olympic year now you could be the
fastest runner in the world and it's an
off year and so you know by the time you
get to the Olympics three years later
you know you aren't anymore so there's a
lot of luck involved in things in the
world so at 30 I started Wine Library TV
youtube blows up at 31 I'm on Conan
O'Brien Ellen there's articles being
written about me now they're writing
that the business grew from 3 to 60
million dollars in sales I'm becoming
this guy I got so many goddamn emails
from friends in high school during that
period when I was showing up in all
these magazines and TV shows and every
single one of them was like hey Gary you
remember me from high school oh my god
you're so lucky I wrote back every
single one of them and said let me just
clarify one thing I'm not lucky I worked
I worked every goddamn weekend at every
holiday since I was 14 years old so you
can keep that luck [ __ ] in your pocket
my intention with this video was despite
understanding not fighting I want you to
see that it's not one point of view or
the other you can pull and learn from
both especially the one that you don't
immediately resonate with embrace the
genius of the end